it's been a long road from the shores of
the Black Sea where he was born to
dominating Turkish politics for more
than two decades
as a Young Man receptive erdogan seemed
to favor career as a professional
football player
but politics was never far away and by
1994 erdogan was elected as mayor of
Istanbul
whoever wins Istanbul wins turkey a
saying that proved true for erdogan
but the road to power wasn't always
smooth erdogan was at the same time
feared adored and reviled for his sharp
tongue and religiously conservative
leanings
foreign his time as mayor ended with a
four-month jail sentence for violating
the secular principles of the country
his critics today still accuse him of
changing those principles
but erdogan went ahead unperturbed in
2001 he founded the justice and
development party or act party
a crucial stepping stone that led him to
become Prime Minister for three
consecutive terms before becoming
president
those were times of economic growth and
reforms Millions were taken out of
poverty and the middle class grew
stronger ambitious projects and plans
flourished conservatives also hailed him
for supporting their rights to express
religion openly allowing women to wear
headscarves in universities and
government offices
but critics also a grew Bolder a protest
against Plans to overhaul a park in
Istanbul quickly turned into a challenge
to what demonstrators called a growing
authoritarian rule
nature in 2016
failed military coup Rebel soldiers and
followers of fatula gulen are once
political Ally of erdogan came close to
capturing the president
a tough Crackdown followed tens of
thousands were imprisoned
the Crackdown calls alarm abroad at a
time where relations with the EU were
Frosty because of the influx of refugees
going into Greece from Turkey
[Music]
in response erdogan cemented his grip on
power winning a referendum that granted
him more presidential powers
but it was a narrow Victory and in 2019
his act party lost Istanbul
that was a turning point since then
erdogan has faced many challenges this
election shows turkey a has become a
nation very much polarized but if
anything erdogan will remain the man who
took Mustafa kemales at a Turks Republic
and remade it in his own image
al-jazeera
well as Huda said that was a turning
point how